what are you in the rap game what do you
do the best me I do me the best
um I would
say I would say that I'm
uh like a
LeBron you know the fen I'm I started
Dro My First solo album when I was 14
and that's the Same album I'm talking
about that went platinum so thefe I'm
came out and I stuck some that came
out and I've been doing this at this
pace of higher ever since just like him
and you're kind of still right now today
it's kind of
like it's so crazy that you remember Tom
Brady was remember every year was still
even though he was winning the Super
Bowl and all it still was is this a year
he gonna
retire we don't even say that we don't
want you to retire yeah we want you to
stay forever that's what I'm saying so I
I kind of look at that as when people
ask me like when to call the Six coming
out I like God damn it that's six of
them and they still want it and that's
how I look at that you know so I am so
happy that you explained it in that way
because I had this thought today that I
feel like people don't realize that you
were one of the first like young stars
that actually became a superstar that
you have done this your whole life life
and I think about LeBron I think about
Serena and the ways that you all met the
expectation but then exceeded the
expectation and it is very rare to
become the person that you're supposed
to become do you ever sit and think
about that definitely because being that
person you was talking about you that
you in your head you can only imagine
what the what the person you said to be
I don't think we ever you know even if
we do get to that person we
automatically set another person you
know what I'm saying so I think that's
and that's the reason why I still work
the way I work every day yeah and also
from coming from so young back then I
think the longevity thing was the
approach you know cuz we knew not to
approach it that way you know cuz I was
literally the same age and stuff as Lil
Bow and L Romeo and stuff you know like
I had shows and we would have I but I'm
not about to get on here and talk about
what they talk about I'm going to talk
about what's real to me and that's it
was already adult conversation yeah you
know and so it already made me that's my
long mean and so therefore if I'm
starting off here and I'm only 14 I can
I got time to make it to an adult
actually 100% start meaning what I say
yeah for sure like I got time to get
there
yeah